so now we begin on four classes on
number theory the purpose of taking it
up now is that we're still practicing
proofs and number theory is a nice
self-contained elementary subject as
we'll treat it which has some quite
elegant proofs and illustrates
contradiction and other structure
structures that we've learned about a
little bit of induction and definitely
some applications of the well ordering
principle oh the ultimate punchline of
the whole unit is to understand the RSA
cryptosystem and how it works along the
way we will today actually establish one
of those mothers milk facts that we all
take for granted about unique
factorization of integers into primes
but in fact that's a theorem that merits
some proof as an example in the homework
shows where we exhibited a system of
numbers which didn't factor uniquely and
finally we will be able to knock off the
die-hard story once and for all so let's
begin by stating the rules of the game
we're going to assume all of the usual
algebraic rules for addition and
multiplication and subtraction so you
may know some of these rules have names
like the first equality is called
distributivity of multiplication over
plus x over plus and then the second
rule here is called commutativity of
multiplication and here are some more
familiar rules this is called
associativity of multiplication this is
called the additive identity a minus a
is 0 or actually additive inverse 0 is
the additive identity and minus a is the
inverse of a a plus 0 equals a is the
definition of 0 being an additive
identity a plus 1 is greater than a so
these are all standard algebraic facts
that we're going to take for granted and
not worry about and one more fact that
we also know
and we're gonna take as an axiom if I
divide a number a positive number sorry
if I divide a number a by a positive
number B then when we're talking about
integers what I'm gonna get is a
quotient and a remainder what's the
definition of the quotient and a
remainder well the division theorem says
that if I divide a by B that means if I
take the quotient times B plus the
remainder I get a and in fact there's a
unique quotient of a divided by B and is
unique remainder of a divided by B where
the remainder what makes it unique is
the remainder is constrained to be in
the interval greater than equal to zero
and less than the divisor B so we're
going to take this fact for granted to
proving it is not worth thinking about
too hard because it's one of those facts
that's so elementary that it's hard to
think of other things that would more
legitimately prove it I'm sure it could
be proved by induction but I haven't
really thought that throat okay a key
relation that we're going to be looking
at today is the relation of divisibility
between integers so by the way all of
the variables for the next week or so
are gonna be understood to range over
the integers so when I say number I mean
integer when I talk about variables a at
C and K I mean if they're taking integer
values so I'm going to define C divides
a using this vertical bar notation it's
reddy's divided c divides a if and only
if a is equal to K times C for some K
and there are a variety of synonyms for
a divides B like a is a a a device II
sorry C divides a is to say that a is a
multiple of C and C is a divisor of a
okay let's just practice this so five
device 15 well because fifteen is three
five a number n divides zero every
number n divides or even zero divides
zero because zero is equal to zero times
n so zero is a multiple of every number
another trivial fact that follows from
the definition is that if C divides a
then C divides any constant times a well
let's just check that out how it follows
from the definition if I'm given that
seed divides a that means that a is
equal to K prime C for some K Prime that
implies that if I multiply both sides of
this equality by s I get that si is
equal to SK prime C and if I parentheses
the SK prime I can call that to be K and
I found sure enough that si is a
multiple of C that's a trivial program
which is practicing with the definitions
so we just verified this fact that if C
divides a then C divides a constant
times a as a matter of fact if C divides
a and C divides B then C divides a plus
B let's just check that one what we've
got is C divides a means that that a is
equal to K 1 times C and C divides B
means that B is equal to K 2 times C so
that means that a plus B is simply K 1
plus K 2 times C or what I've done is
here is used the distributivity law to
factor C out and use the fact that
multiplication is commutative so I can
factor out on either side okay let's put
those facts together
if seat divides a and C divides B then C
divides si plus TB where S&T or any
integers at all so a combination of two
numbers a and B like this it's called a
linear combination of a and B an integer
linear
but since we're only talking about
integers I'm gonna stop saying integer
linear combination and just say linear
combination a linear combination of a
and B is what you get by multiplying
them by coefficients S&T and adding them
okay
so we've just figured out that in fact
if C divides a and C divides B then C
divides an integer linear combination of
B when C divides two numbers it's called
a common divisor of those two numbers so
we can rephrase this observation by
saying common divisors of a and B divide
integer linear combinations of a and B
which is a good fact to just file away
in your head now what we're gonna be
focusing on for the rest of today is the
concept of the greatest common divisor
of a and B called the GCD of a and B the
greatest common divisor of a and B
exists by the well ordering principle
because it's a set of non-negative
integers with an upper bound namely a is
an upper bound on the greatest common
divisor of a and B and so as we did in
an exercise or I think in the text that
implies that there will be a greatest
one among all the common divisors
assuming there are any but one is always
a common divisor so they're they're
gonna intend to be some let's look at
some examples the greatest common
divisor of 10 and 12
you can check it's two mainly because
the 10 factors into 2 times 5 and 12
factors into 2 times 6 and the 6 and the
5 have no common factors so the only one
that they share is 2 the GCD of 13 and
12 is 1 or they have no common factors
in in common you can see that because 13
is a prime and so it has no factors
other than 1 and 13 and 13 doesn't
divide 12 because it's too big so it's
got to be 1
the GCD of 17 and 17 is 17 that's a
general phenomenon the GCD of N and n is
always n the greatest common divisor of
0 and n is equal to n for any positive n
that's because everything is a divisor
of 0 and it means the GCD of 0 and n is
simply the greatest divisor of n which
is of course n by itself
one final fact set things up for the
next segment is to think about the GCD
of a prime and a number and it's either
1 or pay the reason is that the only
divisors of a prime are plus minus 1 and
plus minus P so if P divides a the GCD
is P and otherwise the GCD is 1